en revanche le reste de l'ile-de-france
est assez bien pourvue en base de
loisirs nous le voyons depuis le début
de cet été en faisant le tour des
terrains aménagés dans la région
parisienne
ce soir michel vial nous donne une
preuve de plus qui nous emmène sur la
base de loisirs de cergy neuville
créé à l'origine pour accueillir toutes
les couches de la population
particulièrement celles qui ne partent
pas en vacances
les bases de plein air et de loisir
comme celle de cergy neuville semble
avoir réussi au delà de toutes les
prévisions
plus d'un million de personnes ont en
effet fréquenté en 1981
plus de quarante mille pour la seule
journée du 14 juillet ce succès paraît
donc le signe d'un besoin qui a
peut-être été créés en la circonstance
mais qui reflète néanmoins une certaine
inspiration à la détente sur un espace
libre et animée
c'est le cas à cergy ou l'équipement de
250 hectares offre à ses usagers des
possibilités variées d'activités
sportives et culturelles dans un cadre
rural préserver du bruit et en ce qui
concerne l'accueil du public de la
jeunesse et du cadre associatif
on commence à atteindre les objectifs
que l'on s'est fixés néanmoins il reste
le problème de la finition des bases de
loisirs et de leur aménagement
car si on prend un exemple comme la
planche à voile qui s'est développée
plus vite que les aménagements et
naturellement c'était imprévisible
on peut parler d'un besoin de centre
nautique la base de loisirs de cergy par
exemple ou d'un hébergement puisqu'il
n'ya aucun hébergement dans le
département du val d'oise
nous ce qu'on veut c'est très simple que
le terrain qui est en bas du pont à la
droite du pont où les voitures peuvent
rentrer et aller stationner qu'ils
soient ouverts le samedi le dimanche
sont le ferment la semaine ça n'a pas
même temps pas mais l'essentiel dimanche
pour que les voitures qui s'en inspirent
l'ombre dans la base de loisirs viennent
s'y installer et ne gêne plus ni les
riverains ni les circulations
intérieures
évidemment ce type de fortes
concentrations populaire ne laisse pas
de poser des problèmes
problème de stationnement certes mais
aussi de sécurité jour et nuit de
surveillance sur lot de promiscuité
autant de points pas toujours facile à
améliorer au fond ces bases de loisirs
où tous pareils prévu conditionné marché
ne s'apparenterait t'elle pas à des
vacances pour assister sans aucune place
pour l'imagination où l'initiative les
bases de loisirs celle inverse de ce que
vous venez de dire m'excuse mais
justement elles ont été créées pour une
certaine liberté de d'accueil d'une part
une liberté pour chacun de s'exprimer
vous avez vu des gens se baigner hors de
la baignade bon c'est dangereux c'est
interdit mais chacun prend sa
responsabilité et on va pas mettre un
gendarme derrière chaque baigneur on va
pas mettre un gendarme derrière chaque
squatteurs à planche à voile
il ya justement une certaine liberté de
la part des gens et c'est là je crois à
toute la différence peut-être par
rapport au club ou à la plage où tout
est organisé
la garderie etc etc je crois que les
gens qui viennent ici ont cette
sensation de liberté dans l'esprit de
leurs responsables donc la récréation de
plein air vocation première de ce genre
d'établissement va de pair avec la
liberté d'expression la responsabilité
individuelle et collective qui doivent
s'y développer dans le respect
volontaire des autres et des deniers
publics
reste évidemment à savoir si la notion
même de groulx de foule ne dilue pas
plus ou moins ces responsabilités là
mais cela c'est sans nul doute le sujet
d'un autre débat